is a neat way to track all your
medications with your iphone do note
that this feature is currently only
available on ios 16. i signed up for the
public beta so i'm going to show you how
it works you can access medications by
opening up the health app and tap on
browse this is where you can find more
features and here we have the
medications section and boom you can set
schedules and get reminders of when you
need to take them and you can choose the
medication type such as capsules tablets
cream and more forms you can set the
medical strength of dosage and frequency
as well and i love that you can
customize the colors of your medications
here too i use them to track my vitamins
and supplements and not only that if you
have dependents you can share all this
information with your caretakers and
they will be reminded too do you know